Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm going to
try to answer some of the lingering
questions about Dark season three's
ending. At this point I've had a few days
to sit with it and think about all the
questions people are asking in the
comments of my previous videos. I've been
rewatching with all these questions in
mind and I have answers for a few of
them. Before I get into them I should
stress a couple things though. First, as
is custom, this video will contain
spoilers about the ending of the Dark
series. If you haven't watched all three
seasons in their entirety this is your
chance to leave. Second, I'm not a
scientist, but I'm also aware of the fact
that I'm not a scientist. These are
theories based on what the show's
writers chose to present to us on screen.
The ending is open to interpretation and
personally I haven't seen a cohesive
explanation for everything that I've
been able to jump completely on board
with yet. That said there have been three
questions that keep coming up and in
this video I'll share the answers I've
arrived at after investigating the clues
that the storytellers provided. through
the lens of my limited understanding of
the theoretical physics of time travel
and quantum mechanics. The three questions
are: 1. How did Claudia know
about the origin world? 2. How
was she able to set things in motion to
change the outcome in Adam and Eva's
worlds? And finally, how could Jonas
and Martha stop the car crash in the
origin world if that's what led to their
existence in the first place?
The answer to the first question, how did
Claudia know about the origin world, is
something I feel pretty confident about.
Claudia's motivation has been presented
as wanting to save her daughter Regina
who gets cancer in Adam and Eva's worlds.
The oldest version of Claudia has been a
mysterious character because prior to
season 3 we didn't know what she was
really trying to do, and what made her
that way in the 33 years of traveling
she did after surviving the apocalypse
in the bunker. Season 3 provided those
answers. She is in fact trying to save
Regina. In that 33 years she realizes
that no one can really change anything
inside the two world closed loop system.
Adam asks
her the question directly in the finale -
how she knows about the origin world. She
answers, "I spent 33 years looking for
answers in your world and hers. I've
tried to put together the pieces of the
puzzle. To understand how everything can
be reborn from the same family tree over
and over again until I realized that
we're not all part of a knot." She then
refers to Adam and Eva's worlds as a
cancer that must have grown from
something else. The origin world. She put
together that all of the characters from
the Jonas and alt Martha's line wouldn't
exist in the origin world because they
all were born due to time travel. From
there she can eliminate characters from
the family tree and look for possible
candidates out of who's left. When you
look at it this way it's not hard to see
how she landed on Tannhaus as the most
likely source. Was it her parents Doris
and Egon Tiedemann? Was that Katharina's
parents Herman and Helene Albers. Or,
was it the guy who lost his family in a
car accident that also seems uniquely
capable of helping them develop the
time-traveling machine? When she stripped
away all of the characters that are
direct descendants of Martha and Jonas I
feel confident that she would be able to
figure out that Tannhaus was connected
to the origin. that leads directly into
the next question. now that she knows
about the origin world how did she
manage to set things in motion to
reverse what happened there and thus
change the outcomes of things and Adam
and Eva's worlds? this is a more difficult
question to answer, but let's look at
what the writers have been telling us. in
the first season we learned that time
travel is possible and that the past and
future are connected. everything is
connected .everything affects everything
else. we see how characters struggle with
this and how human nature drives them to
want to change things. in season two we
learn more about causal determinism and
we add the idea of the bootstrap paradox.
the determinism angle tells us that
nothing can be changed and that no one
has free will. the bootstrap paradox
explains how some things can exist in
the world because of time travel and
have no discernable origin point. they
exist but we don't know how they came
into existence besides the fact that
they travelled through time. season three
introduced the idea that Eva
describes as quantum entanglement. the
show defines this as a phenomenon that
leads to overlapping realities. basically
during the apocalypse there's a short
period of time that the chain of cause
and effect we learned about in the first
two seasons breaks down. in that instant
there is the possibility for reality to
go in two different directions and Eva
illustrates this to her younger self by
drawing the infinity symbol. at the
center of that you can see two realities
can follow two paths in different
directions and still end up back in the
same place.
the other concept Season three gives us
is the thought experiment of
Schrodinger's cat. Origin world Tannhaus
explains to us that the cat inside the
box
simultaneously exists in both of its
possible states, alive and dead, until
it's observed. from there he goes on to
ask the question of whether it would be
possible for multiple realities to exist
side by side. as far as Dark is concerned the
answer is absolutely yes.
we see Adam and Eva's world existing
side-by-side and Eva takes it further by
exploiting the quantum entanglement. she
forces two overlapping realities to
exist simultaneously. one where Adam
kills Martha and her unborn child, and one
where Jonas dies so that Martha can give
birth to the Unknown. when you think
about quantum entanglement and
introducing it to the story it makes you
wonder what all the determinism stuff
was about in the first two seasons. well,
I think that when Origin world Tannhaus
created his time machine the end result
was that he split time and created Adam
and Eva's worlds. they are in fact
deterministic systems where nothing can
be changed. everything that happens has
already been decided and I think this is
backed up by the bootstraps artifacts
and characters that we know couldn't
possibly exist without time-travel.
Claudia explains to Adam that this will
always turn out this way.
Jonas and Martha will always meet and
she'll become pregnant. that will lead to
the Unknown being born and he'll
continue to make sure the apocalypses happen so that the material necessary
for time travel will be created. he will
always impregnate agnes nielsen in both
worlds which will always lead
all these characters being born. Adam
will always try to destroy that not and
Eva will always split the realities so
that she can preserve it. what that says
about Claudia's role is up for debate.
when she visits Adam she believes it's
the first time that happened. based on
the quantum entanglement idea they
introduced she uses Eva's exploit to
split from her reality that takes her
back in time to continue the loop and
eventually get killed by Noah.
simultaneously in the second reality she
goes to visit Adam and that sets off the
chain of events that leads Jonas and
Martha to stop the car crash. I think
there's a strong argument that could be
made that this always happens as well.
the other concept they introduced,
Schrodinger's cat, is reliant on all
possible outcomes existing until the cat
is observed. and I think here is where I
will diverge from calling it the origin
world to calling it the origin reality.
we could think of Tannhaus' origin
reality as a place that can exist in two
states. one where his family dies and one
where they live. in the one where they
die he builds a time machine that splits
time to create Adam and Eva's
deterministic worlds and things
eventually loop around until they reach
the point where they cross over. I think
based on how the story was written and
how the information was presented to us
we can think of the Jonas and Martha as
the observer in the thought experiment
that Tannhaus describes at the
beginning of episode 7. when they observe
Marek and Sonja turning around and thus
surviving, that forces the origin reality
into a definite state. they survive. Tannhaus never creates a time machine and
that forces the origin reality into a definite state. for me that
answers the last question on the list,
how could Jonas and Martha stop the
car crashed in the origin world if
that's what led to their existence in
the first place? I think the story is
telling us that Jonas and Martha are what
I can only think to describe as quantum
time travelers and their actions in the
origin reality forced the linear time
line there where Tannhaus family lives.
the only people that can exist in that
reality are people who were never born
from
Jonas and Martha's line and I think this
is all wrapped up pretty well whenever
they showed the dinner scene and close
out the series that way. so Claudia's
discovering the origin world figuring
out how the knot was constructed and
then utilizing Eva's exploit guarantees
that this is how this reality will play
out. again I think this all adds up to
the storytellers telling us that this
isn't part of a bigger loop because that
state of the Tannhaus' family dying no
longer exists. it is open to our
interpretation though and there's a lot
of different ways you can go. I like this
one. I think it's a good idea for how you
can take something that presents that
deterministic system but also provides a
way for things to change. without Claudia
using the exploit essentially the only
ending that exists is one where the
cycle just repeats itself over and over
again. the alternate ending that a lot of
people thought they saw coming whenever
Jonas and Martha entered the origin
reality was that they are the ones who
caused the crash and thus the cycle was
just bigger than what we could see or
the loop I guess. but I think in the end
this is more satisfying. it uses the
concepts they introduced in season 3 to
get around the grandfather paradox and
even though the characters who were born
of the knot no longer exist all of what
they went through wasn't for nothing. the
group of characters we have at that
dinner table continued to exist and Tannhaus actually saves his family by
creating time travel even though he has
no memory of any of that happening. so
with that I'll leave it there there are
a lot of other questions so I'll
probably have some more videos in the
next couple of days let me know what you
think about this idea what you think
about the ending in general if there's
anything you like to add just do that in
the comments please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon